"
CHRISTMAS IS COMING UP REAL
QUICK.
LET'S SWITCH THINGS UP AND HAVE
A LITTLE BIT OF FUN AND DO A
HOLIDAY THEMED FASTEST.
FIRST UP.
MILLIONS OF CHILDREN ARE EAGERLY
ANTICIPATING THE JOY OF
UNWRAPPING THEIR CHRISTMAS
PRESENTS.
HOWEVER, SOME PARENTS ARE ACTING
LIKE THE GRINCH.
A VIRAL SOCIAL MEDIA TREND HAS
THOUSANDS OF MOM PLACING OF BAN
ON GIFTING THEIR CHILDREN TRENDY
TOYS AND TANGIBLE ITEMS.
"AT THE END OF THE DAY, IT'S ALL
JUST JUNK."
IN STEAD OF TOYS, KIDS OR GIFTED
EDUCATIONAL OR FUN EXPERIENCES
LIKE TICKETS TO A MUSEUM OR A
TRIP TO DISNEYLAND.
DISNEYLAND SEEMS FUN.
>> Dana: I'M NOT APPARENT.
>> Jessica: YOU GIFT TO KIDS.
>> Dana: DISNEYLAND SEEMS
WHIMSICAL AND FUN.
IF I WAS A KID AND GOT TO TRIP
TO DISNEYLAND, I WOULD PROBABLY
BE VERY.
I'M NOT JUDGING ANYBODY.
DO WHATEVER YOU WANT WITH YOUR
KIDS.
I THOUGHT IT WAS INTERESTING,
THE MAIN GIFT KIDS WERE ASKING
FOR THIS YEAR WERE ROBUCKS,
DIGITAL MONEY KIDS CAN SPEND.
IS THAT WHERE YOUR KIDS GO?
THEY BUY THINGS FOR VIRTUAL
MONEY.
ANYWAY, I DON'T REALLY
UNDERSTAND IT AND I DON'T THINK
SAM BANK --
SAM BANK MEN FREED IS BEHIND IT.
IF IT'S JUNK, THROWN AWAY OR
GIVE IT TO WHO NEEDS IT.
>> Jesse: I'M GOING TO GET
THEM TICKETS TO THE MAT.
DANA, I AM JUDGING THESE
PARENTS, JUDGING THEM HARSHLY.
JUDGE COMEY WOULD PROBABLY AGREE
LEGAL YOU CAN CHARGE THE PARENTS
WITH CHILD ABUSE.
THEY'RE EITHER CHEAP OR LIBERAL.
THE WHOLE POINT OF CHRISTMAS
MORNING IS THE PHYSICAL
UNWRAPPING OF THE GIFTS.
IT'S THE RIPPING OF THE WRAPPING
PAPER, SURPRISE ON THEIR FACES,
CREATION OF PILES.
THAT'S THE EXPERIENCE.
YOU DON'T WANT TO GET AN
EXPERIENCE.
YOU WANT TO EXPERIENCE THE
UNWRAPPING A PHYSICAL GIFT.
ANY PARENT THAT DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND THAT IS STUPID.
WE ARE GOING TO BRING THEM UP ON
SERIOUS CHARGES.
>> Jessica: WHAT ABOUT
UNWRAPPING A TIE, LIKE THIS
BEAUTY.
>> Jesse: THIS WAS THE GIFT
EXCHANGE, THE TAPING OF THE
"THE FIVE" SPECIAL.
IT'S A GUTFELD TIE.
HOPEFULLY I'M NOT ADDING TO HIS
BANK ACCOUNT BY HAVING THIS.
I WEAR IT PROUDLY AND IT LOOKS
GOOD.
THE PRIME TIME ONE, WE ARE
WORKING ON THAT.
>> Jessica: JUDGE, WHAT ARE
YOU GETTING YOUR GRANDSON?
>> Judge Jeanine: EVERY MEMBER
CHRISTMAS EVE AS BEING THE WORST
NIGHT OF THE YEAR.
YOU KNOW WHY?
AFTER THE KIDS WENT TO BED.
I DID ALL THE COOKING, THAT'S
TRUE.
THE KIDS WENT TO BED WE HAD PUT
TOGETHER THE GAMES, THE TRAIN,
WHATEVER.
ALL NIGHT LONG.
WE COULD PUT IT IN FRONT OF THE
CHRISTMAS TREE IN THE MORNING.
SOMETIMES I THINK THAT WE BUY
THINGS FOR KIDS THAT ARE SO
OVER-THE-TOP AND SO RIDICULOUS.
IT'S ALMOST ABOUT SELF GUILT.
LIKE WE ARE NOT AS GOOD A PARENT
IF WE DON'T SPEND THAT MUCH
MONEY.
I KIND OF LOOK AT THIS A
DIFFERENT WAY.
I KIND OF LOOK AT IT AS, MAYBE
WE HAVE OVER DONE SOME STUFF.
MAYBE A LITTLE EDUCATIONAL
STUFF.
MAYBE THIS, THAT, OBVIOUSLY PUT
THE BOXES IN THE MIDDLE OF IT.
KIDS ARE HAPPY.
MY GRANDSON WILL PROBABLY GET A
POT OUT OF THE CABINET AND
PLAYING WITH IT.
I GOT THEM ALL KINDS OF THINGS.
>> Jesse: THAT'S TRUE, YOU CAN
SPEND HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS ON
THESE EXPENSIVE GIFTS AND THEN
YOU GIVE THE KID A STICK OR A
BALL FOR $2 AND THEY LOVE IT.
>> Tom: THAT'S ALL YOU NEED.
MY PARENTS WERE A LOT MORE HARSH
THAN THESE ONES.
THIS WOMAN WHO WROTE THE ARTICLE
SAID THEY TAKE THE KIDS SKIING
TO BIG BEAR OR GO TO
DISNEY WORLD.
WE DIDN'T HAVE DISNEY WORLD.
I WOULD BEG TO GO TO
DISNEY WORLD.
MY DAD WOULD SAY LOOK AT THE
VIEWMASTER.
LOOK AT THE PICTURES OF DISNEY.
THAT'S ALL AHEAD AS A KID.
I USED TO GIVE MY KIDS, THE BEST
GIFT, WHENEVER I WAS ON THE
ROAD, MY HOTEL KEYS.
I WOULD GIVE THEM EACH, I WOULD
SAY HERE'S A CREDIT CARD AND
THEY WOULD PLAY WITH THE
CREDIT CARD.
THEY WOULD PRETEND THEY WERE
HAVE A STORY.
>> Dana: YOU'RE AT THE FRONT
DESK CHECKING IN, YOU WOULD SAY
"I NEED TWO KEYS."
>> Tom: I WOULD WALK OUT WITH
THE KEYS AND JUST GIVE THEM TO
MY KIDS.
WHEN I WAS A KID, MY TEACHER IN
SECOND GRADE SAID YOU CAN BRING
IN FOR SHOW AND TELL ONE GIFT
BUT ONLY ONE GIFT AT ALL THE
KIDS WERE LIKE "ONLY ONE."
I WAS LIKE, "I ONLY GOT ONE."
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jessica: UP NEXT, IT'S
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO AVOID THE
HOLIDAY SWEETS YOUR COWORKERS
BRING TO THE OFFICE.
YOU CAN HEAR IT.
THE JUDGE IS DEFINITELY NOT
GUILTY OF THIS.
THE SUGARY TEMPTATIONS CAN GO UP
YOUR DIET AND CREATE STRANGE
OFFICE MOMENTS IF NO ONE WANTS
TO EAT YOUR HOMEMADE PECAN PIE.
ALLOW ME TO TEMPT EVERYONE AT
THE TABLE WITH THESE DELICIOUS
COOKIES.
>> Dana: IT'S BEEN AN ENTIRE
DAY OF COOKIES.
>> Judge Jeanine: I WILL HAVE
ONE OF THOSE.
WHAT IS THIS?
>> Jessica: MANY CUPCAKES.
HAVE YOU BEEN EATING A LOT AT
THE OFFICE?
>> Dana: THERE'S A REALLY NICE
HUNG ON WHO WORKS FOR THE
"GUTFELD!"
SHOW CALLED ANDRE AND HE BROUGHT
IN A TREAT.
PRETZELS, CHECK NEXT CONCOCTION.
IT WAS A CUTE BAG AND HE WAS
GIVING OUT.
I THANKED HIM PROFUSELY AND GAVE
IT TO MY ASSISTANT AND MADE HER
EAT IT.
>> Judge Jeanine: INCREDIBLE
DISCIPLINE.
>> Dana: I HAVE TO.
I AM ONLY 5 FEET TALL.
>> Judge Jeanine: I AM NO
GIANT AND I JUST KEEP EATING.
>> Jessica: OUR PEOPLE HOME
BAKING?
I DON'T SEE IT THAT MUCH.
>> Tom: THERE IS THREE WOMEN
IN MY HOUSE AND THEY ARE ALWAYS
BAKING COOKIES, EVERYTHING ELSE.
PEOPLE THINK THAT I HAVE
WILLPOWER.
I'M NOT THAT INTO A TREAT SOME
THINGS.
MY WIFE IS, LIKE, SHE WILL GET A
DESERT AND BE LIKE, DO YOU WANT
TO BITE?
I WILL BE LIKE, I WILL HAVE SOME
LATER.
SHE IS LIKE, THERE WILL NOT BE A
LEADER.
>> Dana: I LIKE YOUNG PEOPLE
BRING THINGS TO THE OFFICE.
IT'S VERY COMMUNAL.
I LIKE IT WHEN PEOPLE BRING
THINGS TO THE OFFICE.
>> Judge Jeanine: IT'S GOOD.
>> Jessica: I WILL COME BACK
TO YOU WHEN YOU'RE DONE WITH
THAT.
JESSICA HAVE YOU BEEN OVER
EATING AT THE OFFICE?
>> Jesse: NO.
I ONLY HAVE ONE THING.
>> Jessica: PER DAY.
>> Jesse: TO BE NICE.
I DON'T WANT TO BE RUDE.
IF SOMEONE PUTS OUT SOMETHING
AND I'M ON CAMERA.
I'M NOT GOING BEHIND THE SCENES,
STUFFING MYSELF.
>> Dana: TRY THAT CANDYCANE
COOKIE AND TELL ME IF IT'S ANY
GOOD.
>> Jesse: THE RED AND WHITE
ONE?
NOW I WILL HAVE HAD TWO.
>> Judge Jeanine: THE MINI
CUPCAKE IS FRESH AND DELICIOUS.
>> Jessica: THAT BIG COOKIE
LOOKS GOOD.
>> Jesse: ARE YOU EATING
VICARIOUSLY THROUGH ME?
>> Dana: YES.
[LAUGHS]
I OFTEN DO THAT.
IT'S FUNNY.
NO ONE HAS EVER CAUGHT ME ON
THAT BUT IT'S TRUE.
I WANT TO SMELL IT.
>> Jessica: OKAY, NOBODY WANTS
A CHRISTMAS COLD BUT
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S THAT TIME OF
THE YEAR, ON AVERAGE ADULTS
REPORT GETTING 63 TIMES A YEAR
BY 3 OUT OF 4 PEOPLE SECRETLY
ENJOY THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE A
BREAK.
>> Dana: LAST YEAR AT
CHRISTMAS ON THE 23RD.
WE HAD ALL THESE TAPINGS, THE
FIRST YEAR OF DOING TWO SHOWS,
AMERICA'S NEWSROOM AND
"THE FIVE."
I WAS SO LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
BREAK.
PERCY WAS THE TINY PUPPY.
I WAS GOING TO HAVE A WHOLE WEEK
OFF.
ON THE 23RD, I DIDN'T FEEL
GREAT.
24TH, IT WAS COVID.
I WAS SO SICK UNTIL JANUARY 3RD
AND THEN I CAME BACK TO THE
OFFICE.
I FEEL THE HEALTHIEST I'VE FELT
ALL YEAR RIGHT NOW AND I KNOW
I'M LIVING ON BORROWED TIME
BECAUSE EVERY TIME YOU TURN
AROUND, SOMEBODY IN THIS PLACE
IS SICK.
PEOPLE COME TO WORK.
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY, PEOPLE
ARE DEALING WITH IT.
I'M REALLY HOPEFUL THAT I CAN
GET THAT WEEK FOR IT CATCHES ME.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU ARE
GOING AWAY NEXT WEEK.
YOU HAVE A CHANCE.
>> Dana: I'M TRYING NOT TO DO
ANYTHING.
I'M NOT GOING TO WEAR A MASK
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T WORK ANYWAY.
>> Jesse: I DON'T GET SICK BUT
I TAKE PERSONAL DAYS.
IF I FEEL TIRED, I WILL TAKE A
PERSONAL DAY BUT I DON'T GET
SICK.
THAT'S WHY I DON'T GET SICK.
I PREEMPTIVELY.
A LOT OF SELF-RESPECT FOR
MYSELF.
>> Jessica: YOU'RE ALWAYS
EATING FRUIT.
YOU'RE PRETTY HEALTHY.
>> Jesse: I'M GETTING A REALLY
GOOD REPUTATION.
>> Jessica: JUST THE A BLOG.
B BLOCK WILL BE WORSE.
>> Jesse: THERE'S OTHER THINGS
I DO.
I DO DRINK A LOT.
>> Tom: I WOULD POWER THROUGH.
I WOULD DO DAYQUIL, COME TO WORK
ANYWAY AND TRY TO PRETEND THAT I
WASN'T SICK.
I'M NOT --
MY WIFE IS A REAL CARETAKER AND
I LOOK AT SICKNESS AS A SIGN OF
WEAKNESS.
IT'S NOT A GOOD MATCH.
I'M HOME.
EVERY 5 MINUTES, I AM HOME.
I REACT.
>> Dana: MY MOM WOULD SEND ME
A TEXT.
I'M FINE.
EVEN THOUGH I WASN'T FINE.
THIS IS A BAD THING ABOUT ME.
IF PETER EVER SAYS, I FEEL LIKE
I'M COMING DOWN WITH SOMETHING,
MY FIRST REACTION EVERY TIME IS,
I HOPE I DON'T GET IT.
THAT'S RUDE, RIGHT?
>> Jesse: I SEE OTHER PEOPLE
SICK AND I THINK THEY ARE WEAK
BUT THEN WHEN I GET SICK I AM
LIKE "TAKE CARE OF ME."
>> Jessica: JUDGE.
YOU DON'T GET SICK.
>> Judge Jeanine: I DON'T GET
SICK.
IT'S VERY RARE.
MOST PEOPLE AVERAGE THREE
SICKNESSES A YEAR, I THOUGHT, I
DON'T DO THAT AT ALL.
WHEN YOU START FEELING WEAK AND
THEN YOU EAT SUGAR, THAT'S THE
WORST THING YOU CAN DO.
SUGAR IS --
IT WEAKENS YOU.
I PRETTY MUCH KNOW WHAT TO DO.
I MAKE MY OWN CHICKEN SOUP.
I MAKE GREAT CHICKEN SOUP AND
THEN IT'S OVER.
>> Dana: HAVE YOU SEEN THESE
NEW THINGS?
I HAVEN'T NEEDED ONE BUT I HAVE
THEM JUST IN CASE.
IT'S LIKE, THE SHOWER STEAMER
THING.
LIKE VICKS VAPOR RUB BUT IT'S IN
THE SHOWER STEAMER.
IN THE SHOWER YOU PUT IT IN AND
THE STEAM GET ALL PAUL AND YOUR
SINUSES SO YOU CAN GET BETTER.
>> Tom: I PUT MY FACE OVER THE
CATTLE IN THE MORNING.
>> Dana: LOOK AT YOUR SKIN,
IT'S AMAZING.
>> Jessica: I LI